الاربع مباريات فقط تفصلنا عن نهايه كاس
العالم لكره القدم والبحث مستمر عن كسر
عقده الرقم 6 منذ عام 2006 لم يتمكن هداف
البطوله من تسجيل اكثر من سته اهداف والان
الامر متاح
لثلاثه لاعبين في هذه البطوله
السباق ينحصر بين الفرنسيك اليان مبابي
الذي يتصدر ترتيب هدافي البطوله بخمسه
اهداف اللاعب البالغ من العمر 23 عاما سجل
هدفا في مرمى استراليا في المباراه
الافتتاحيه لفريقه قبل ان يهز الشباك
الدانمارك بهدفين المباراه الثانيه ثم عاد
بامبي لي ضيف هدفين امام منتخب بولندا في
الدوري الثاني
المركز الثاني
للهدافين
يتقسمه لاعبا الارجنتينيون المسي والفرنسي
اوليفييو برصيد اربعه اهداف لكل منهما
افتتح ميسي عدد اهدافه من نقطه الجزاء في
المباراه التي خسرها امام السعوديه بينما
جاء الهدف الثاني امام المكسيك في الدوري
الاول في الدوري اللاحقين سجل ميسي هدفا
امام استراليا كما هز شبه كلندا بدور
الثمانيه نختتم مع اوليفياجيرو صاحب
الاهداف الاربعه مثل ميسي المهاجم الفرنسي
احرز ثنائيه في مرمى استراليا بدور
المجموعات قبل ان يسجل هدفا امام بولندا
في الدوري الثاني ويوم امس سجل جيرو هدف
فوز فرنسا على انجلترا في دور الثمانيه
ليقوده منتخب الديوك للمربع الذهبي